junkies movie fights Oh what the f it's
movie fights what's going on you guys
hashtag movie fights live let's have
some fun we got some great competitors
oh so I gotta give a shout out hoot
hashtag all nation and look at this it's
Percival's girlfriend Lou Lou Lou the
owl a new owl a new lady owl in the nest
let's meet our combatants normally he's
locked in the booth with a bowl of water
but he's out and he's ready to fight
yeah this happening it's good to be back
hospital bosses about movie fights I'm
still rockin with Lloyd Christmas tooth
here might as well just keep it to
Halloween find my Jeff Daniels if you're
out there you're rockin the Lloyd
Christmas but it's good Aspen yes
hopefully you are not the dumber and
dumber east of the fight today a second
turnover from FX movie download and
she's the mom to Luna engine a little
outlet sasha pearl raver always great to
have you so glad to be here JT e we will
still be friends at the end of this
course yes
which is the best rocky again one
through eight I'm comic reads what four
four five
are coming in guns blazing oh yeah
straight from the gym my biological
father my son Scott manse how Rudnik
it's great to be here guys I'd like you
know it we have known each other for so
long now we have fought in the ring we
have fought out of the ring but you guys
are my friends
and I stay that way after this fight I
hope you will stay my son after this
fight this is gonna be a great fight I'm
impartial I'm not pulling for you dad
judged equally and also and also judging
equally and honestly are my friends over
on the Dan cam
mr. Dan were all holding Dan whirlwind
Merle that's how you that's how you
movie fight you are a whirlwind of facts
and figures over there I appreciate them
great to see you buddy and I like both
your shirts you're wearing a Jurassic
Park rescuers down under I'm an adult
we're fans fandom knows no age and an
ageless wonder a delightful friend the
friend the BFF of the Internet
Daniel Radford hiding it what you know
what Danielle okay so Dan is wearing
Theresa Parker tail shirt and Danielle
looks like you're wearing
pterodactyls on your shirt so theme
going Raptors right these feathered
Raptors Danielle would you please tell
us how your capacity as social media
ambassador works all right so the way
this works is I am the voice of you and
the voice of the people there are tons
of really fun polls on Twitter I
encourage you to join those and join the
conversation on movie for hashtag movie
fights live but for our purposes our
polls work as a tiebreaker so if we
can't get it together we are trusting
you it's a bad idea we do it every week
I'm going in on the polls those do not
go up into the arguments have been
presented because it is about the
arguments if you have any questions
about getting the poll to work for you
on YouTube which is where the pool
counts go ahead and drop a line in the
chat I'm sure someone will help you out
with that and I look forward to reading
all of your great theories and stuff on
movie fights live hashtag and if I like
it I might shout you out during the show
it means that's my favorite part usually
also take memes yes awesome maybe you'll
get meme calm a dank memes the best I
usually say jte drop that yes yeah but
unless you can use mind control Billy
biz in the booth trouble yes package
[Music]
yeah thank you for okay so let's get
into this the first player again the
rule is the first player to four points
wins top two players move on to the
speed round first player to four points
wins alright question number one okay so
this is going to be a two-on-one round
alright here's the question with so we
all saw the the new Star Wars teaser
trailer Rey jumping over kylo and his
ship so last week we we learned the
surprising return of the Emperor as well
and we asked is putting the emperor in
Episode nine a good idea or a bad idea
is bringing back the Emperor's
mischievous laugh and everything he's
going to do a good idea and a bad idea
so I'm gonna ask that you just give your
initial answers whether it's good or bad
and then we'll elaborate further so
please let's go around the horn starting
with JT I'm gonna say it's good how okay
JT says it's good I'm gonna say it's
good - how Sasha says it's good stuff
okay Scott leave it to me in the being a
voice of reason
bringing the Emperor back for episode 9
is a bad bad bad idea okay I'm just
gonna write down Babylon great thank you
so and it works
thusly if Sasha and JT II when they each
get one point if Scott wins he gets two
points think of this as like ravishing
Rick Rude and Brutus the barber beefcake
against Andre the Giant okay it's like a
handicap match
time to take a back shot to 80s 90s
wrestling okay this is a handicap match
Scott wins two points y'all win with the
good side you get one point a good side
here a good argument Harley the good
side fight it out you guys I want to
hear your ideas now what hear yours
since I clearly outnumbered here I'm
gonna hear what other BS answers you had
before I chopped it with my right let's
not kid ourselves what has these movies
these new trilogy it's basically been a
greatest hits Roadshow every movie we're
just like we're doing Harrison Ford in
there we're throwing some robots you saw
probably for a second in the first movie
the second one I finally got Mark Hamill
they tease them at the ending this one
we got Lando's coming back basically if
you were in the og trilogy they're gonna
find a spot for you in this one so in
order to have the Emperor there he is
the guy that started this whole thing
the prequels is all about the Emperor's
rise and then it's his reign and now
it's his return how that's gonna end
there's a couple ways you could argue it
but it's in order to close this chapter
of all these you know the book of all
these chapters you have to have the main
bad guy
it wasn't mater he took out the Emperor
is the Emperor he needs to be there he
literally just took the words right out
of my mouth when you're doing a trilogy
of trilogies you have to end with a big
note you don't introduce a new villain
here it can't be Vader Vader is not big
enough
the emperor is the only way to go and
one of the things that I love so much
about this is in the trailer they hear
you hear him say no one's ever really
gone we never saw the body on the
Emperor you always knew he was lingering
you always knew he was gonna come back
said I haven't come back in this way is
the only thing that truly does the story
service and truly does fanservice gotcha
okay it really hurts me to say this
because I have such respect for both of
you I have such friendship for both of
you okay I love you both I would move
mountains
the voice of reason here okay bringing
the emperor back for episode 9 it's such
a bad idea and you hit the nail on the
head this new trilogy has been like a
greatest hits out Greatest Hits albums
suck nobody remembers our greatest hits
out everybody remembers the original
album everybody remembers back in black
everybody remembers Sergeant Pepper
everybody remembers the doors everybody
remembers Ok Computer everybody
remembers Exile on Main Street they
don't remember the Greatest Hits and so
far this new trilogy has already brought
you by classic rock because yeah ok you
brought that now listen you brought back
hon you brought back Leia now you're
bringing back Lando you brought back
Luke ok let's see who's left the Emperor
you know what why don't you do something
different it doesn't have to be the
Emperor by the way what happened to like
may be a great surprise there should
have been a big surprise which where's
the I am your father surprise moment of
this new trilogy it doesn't have one
this could have been a great chance for
for there to be a surprise and now you
blew it because you heard the Emperor's
laugh-in destroyer you know you've left
no room for surprise and by the way no
wait here's why this is a bad idea
so in the original trilogy the rebels
fought back against the Empire it led to
this final showdown with Luke Skywalker
fighting his father and the Emperor and
the and Vader turning on the upper
throwing them over the rail and you seen
this big explosion clearly that was the
Emperor exploding but so you mean to
tell me that the ampere is gonna come
back in episode 9 which basically means
that all of the sacrifice all of the
stuff the loss everything that our
beloved characters endured in the
original trilogy were for nothing
no because that's it everything that's
built up to this moment oh and all that
build-up and I have a question are you
saying that there's no room for surprise
so are you saying you wish that they'd
held it back from the trailer or are you
saying you wish they'd held it back from
the series because I feel like there is
no other villain that would truly feel
big enough like who's a big enough
villain outside of them you know what
Vader is a much better build Esther
you're also your
assuming that he survived the fall he's
coming back as like a guide missing arm
or something he could just be a ghost he
could still be in strings
he's think what I described earlier I
would love to see that trilogy that's
not what this trilogy has been so far no
I know it has it disappoint right I
agree and I think at this point we got
to stay the course
whatever there is right now and to have
the emperor in there just fits with
everything they've done so far I think
killing off Snoke that was your bad guy
from the next two films and they took
him out halfway through Genesis Snoke
was a waste he was too much like English
like the Emperor so far this new trilogy
okay so the force awakens was basically
a redo period of a new hope last Jedi
the last gen I felt more like an episode
of Battlestar Galactica than an episode
than a Star Wars movie the best of these
new movies whether it's the new trilogy
or the spin-off films has been rogue one
rogue one felt the back to the point
answer your question Sasha I mean yeah I
definitely think if they are going to go
with the Emperor then they should have
held it back but if they are going to go
at the Emperor it's a bad idea because
it should be it should be something
different it should be like what
whatever it is it should be something
that we're not seeing and it should not
be something that's easy it's not easy
to make it the Emperor and also it also
gives the big fat finger to everyone in
the original trilogy pulling strings the
entire time that's like basically saying
we have seen so many villain of the
weeks in so many films it's like the one
thing who creates the space cloud filled
with debris we don't need that person
who can be easily vanquished we don't
need somebody who comes in for one movie
and it's an arced story of from start to
finish we know exactly what's gonna
happen they're gonna meet the bad guy
they're gonna battle the bad guy they're
gonna defeat the bad guy this has to be
something that is overarching for nine
films and at the end of those nine films
you feel a true sense of completion and
this way with the following films we can
go off to an entire new place and it can
be it won't be Road one it'll be isn't
it like 2,000 years in the future from
here on out it's too safe it's just too
safe
bringing Lando back is too safe before
they want back ting him to pop up cuz I
had no idea she was gonna come in the
search film if anything you would
thought they would have teased him the
second one but so when I saw that
trailer I was like what whites like that
I just did not expect it at all so for
me it is kind of surprising because I
thought he was long gone but again I
think he's gonna come back as a
spiritual safe ghost and I think he's
gonna be there manipulate what's going
on with you know Kyle I just again I
think it's just a like you have you know
you still there's no question I don't
think anyway that of these trilogies the
best trilogy is the middle one episodes
4 5 & 6 market that was the most epic
one it was but then just changed
Hollywood have changed everything for
sure but every film was different every
film went we didn't know where it was
going to go mm-hmm so now what you're
telling me is we know where we know
where episode 9 is going to go and it's
gonna go back to the bring it back to
the Emperor who's been pulling the
strings for the whole time it's such a
cop-out you're just basically saying
he's saying like I never died Wacka
Wacka Wacka I mean it's just so I made a
cameo the force awakens and you got the
first order it's basically the empire so
like what I'm saying is this from the
get-go and force awakens we're like
we're just kind of redoing everything we
did before so like B side remembers the
greatest hits everybody remembers the
greatest ground all right let's roll
into our final thoughts here and do me a
favor I'd like each of you to end your
final thought with your impression of
the Emperor's laughs okay
JT I'll just say this my favorite thing
in force awakens was seeing her support
come back I thought was the first time I
saw her so far just really fit back
attack character is my favorite thing
about last Jedi was Mark Hamill
seeing him go back in there just being a
character that we grew up and loved but
with a different angle now for me I'm
excited for Lando I think he's gonna be
really fun but for me
knowing that he's coming back the
Emperor just like those first two movies
there's somebody I'm like that's who I
want to see back that's why I want to
see back in the og trilogy in this new
trilogy and it brings me home to the
original trilogy really like that's why
the light tears look forward to mark him
so much I wish they would have seen
together that didn't happen but to have
the Emperor in this third one is like
what I'm looking forward to the most
from the og trilogy appearing in this
one all right Wow Thank You Sasha I
could not disagree more with Scott in
terms of nobody remembering the the
greatest hits we want a compilation of
the songs that you remember we don't
remember every track listing we remember
the things that truly sing for us and
the Emperor is a villain who truly sings
we need that familiarity Star Wars is a
franchise that is based entirely not
entirely I take that back Star Wars is a
franchise that is based largely on fan
familiarity and returning to the roots
of the story so to go back to where we
all started to go back to the thing that
has always been the biggest Archy evil
over this franchise I think that is the
only thing that truly does service to
what people are looking forward to I
think it's a great way to close this
thing out and you're returning to that
first stuff no one is ever really gone
which also means we don't know that
there's not gonna be a Mark Hamill out
or some four things back stairs I think
the staff is voice is the truth I think
that this is what the fans deserve and I
think it's a great choice and my laughs
can be bad
okay thank you for that Apatow laughs I
don't want to hear the greatest hits I
don't want to hear a compilation I don't
want I want to hear a Dark Side of the
Moon
I want to hear sergeant pepper's Lonely
Hearts Club Band
I want to hear the pretenders I want to
hear the album I want to hear something
that breaks ground something that is
trailblazing and first of all what
you're talking about jteem is nostalgia
and we're talking about Star Wars being
about fanservice I completely disagree
with that because when Star Wars was
just Star Wars in 1977 there was no
fanservice because it was the first time
that had been done when the Empire
Strikes Back came out you had all these
different elements that elevated Star
Wars you had Yoda you had you know han
and Leia falling in love you had you
know Luke becoming a Jedi giving and you
had the single greatest moment not just
in the Star Wars series but one of the
greatest moments in movie history the
big reveal with I am your father nobody
saw that coming it was unpredictable and
that's why that still stands out as
probably the greatest moment in all of
the Star Wars movies this movie needs to
end on something that will continue that
that Star Wars will well will live up
its to its to its legacy which it has
not done but really proved that it is
the groundbreaking trailblazing film
series that it is and do something
different not take the easy way out
which is what the Emperor's trying to do
to tie into what you both love about it
which is nostalgia and fanservice
[Laughter]
your bicycle back peewee time thank you
man good stuff
dan where we at boy facts it's all
opinions and based on I did not find a
picture of Fozzie Bear as the Emperor's
[Applause]
favorite there is that there's a popular
meme with Kermit as a sip Thank You
Emperor Fozzie pictures of Muppets you
never you never come back empty-handed
thank you sorry uh you know what Scott I
I fully agree I fully agree but but now
you're trying to put the genie back in
the bottle like you said you brought it
in 1977 we're so far past that and I
think you are dealing with something
that you're dreaming of I think their
argument is based a little bit more in
the reality at hand yeah
Greatest Hits but like I feel like Sasha
made a good point to that you are
pitching a bit of a b-side what's this
new thing that's gonna shock us from out
of nowhere in Episode nine so you've
lost account yeah so at the end of the
day I agree with so much of what you
were saying but we are so far past that
at this point I feel like jte hit the
tone of yeah the Emperor is gonna be
satisfying yeah Sasha we never saw the
body and it could be a ghost so yeah I
got to go with the good side Dan I also
was moved by the classic rock baby
several of the arguments but I didn't
feel like it was framed a little bit and
I think largely by JT particular about
like yes it's a nostalgia and yes we are
leaning into this is this what it's what
fans like it's what they want
but I and and it was back and forth for
me but I actually thought Scott made a
great point in this closing argument
about like I don't want to hear the
greatest hits I want to hear the next
great album I want to hear the next new
album and I thought that was I thought
that was a good argument I thought he
had a very strong closing so I I thought
it was actually a very close fight Scott
had a very very good closing salvo I
think he framed both this argument and
the opposition argument in a very good
way and I actually ended up on his side
of the argument so my vote goes for
Scott it is one one we're going to the
poll Daniel Radford all right this has
been close this entire time oh I'm not
getting trolled okay let me double check
because this is this thing is seriously
been at 5050 for most of this Matt would
work then mom and then y'all has to come
in and give everybody their broccoli in
medicine yes
so with 51 percent of the votes
bad idea
were there any other poignant remarks or
snide comments just a lot of people
talking about classic Robin rocking
Muppets Woodstock that's not a Woodstock
gotcha but I was alive when it happened
now this opens an interesting
possibility yeah last week Danielle had
a clean sweep
but that still required one speedran
question is that it is it's the best of
for a game technically now if Scott were
to get the next two rounds he could
sweep the game without even having to go
to the speed round which would be
another first you receive two points I
am blind here good work Billy thank you
problem it down all right
Scott is up all right here we go
question number two of who we fight so
all three all your no strangers to
reviewing movies yeah and and your word
speaks volumes to me um so we asked what
terribly reviewed movie deserves a
second chance
okay what terribly reviewed stinkeroo
deserves to be revisited and wasn't
given a fair shake and we are going to
start with ms Sascha pro raver
okay I can already hear the chuckles
coming but go with me here yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm gonna say
showgirls showgirls is one of those
movies that everybody wanted to hate and
they got something that was low the ball
it's laughable it's ridiculous but what
is comedy
comedy is tragedy plus time showgirls I
would contend is one of the truly great
camp comedies of our lives
when I say camp I don't mean you know
archery and like canoeing I mean this is
high camp there is a reason that there
are screenings with this movie all the
time once we're elizabeth berkley will
show up and probably go iconic this is
an iconic film dolphin sex iconic what
is it
ver sakes iconic I ain't dog food iconic
when I go to the gym and I do hip
thrusts what do I call them showgirls
because it was part of her audition
montage there's a reason that the one
the only
Alicia Malone loves this film also
sharing a name ish with the lead there
is a reason that Mary genican loves this
movie this was a problem of sexism of
people wanting to go against a teen star
going away from being on Saved by the
Bell and instead like actually owning
her sexuality this is Paul Verhoeven
pushing us beyond what we felt
comfortable with it's okay in Basic
Instinct which is actually not as good
of a movie but it's not okay hearing
showgirls this is about claiming a
European sense of sexuality and pushing
the boundaries we instead decided to go
to our puritanical roots and to that I
say no sir showgirls is the bomb
get on the bus before it blows up Wow
fire real words from Sasha Pearl River
a European sense of sexuality I'm gonna
be unpacking that for a while in my mind
Scott Mass okay great choice thank you
mine's better I'm going with the
greatest showmen from 2017 this movie
only got a fifty six percent on Rotten
Tomatoes yet it made four hundred and
thirty five million dollars worldwide
over an eight week period it never got
higher than number three at the box
office but it did hold its it fell only
less than 20 percent from week to week
which is an incredible hole because
people who saw the movie loved it and
there is a lot to love the music is
great from the songwriters of la-la-land
been cheap a sec and Justin Paul I'm not
gonna get on a while and kick but I do
love the music in the smoothie the song
never enough is fantastic it brought me
to tears and Hugh Jackman who started
2017 playing Logan in the best of the
Wolverine films and ended 2017 as PT
Barnum it just proved that he is indeed
the greatest showman this is a feel-good
crowd-pleaser with a great message
it was rousing it was uplifting critics
be damned
everyone loves this movie and the box
office is the proof all right Scott man
to yourself are a feel-good
crowd-pleaser around the hoard of JT e
these are all I think personal choices
for us for the most part we all love
these movies despite what the Rotten
Tomatoes score is which are all pretty
low for these movies so I'm going with a
personal choice for me and I'm going
with Oliver Stone's Alexander epic film
which even if you don't fully understand
what he was going for which even Oliver
Stone at times doesn't because there's
so many cuts of this movie which I'm
okay with it actually excites me I own
the Blade Runner 5 dis set there's like
cuts a Blade Runner there's like four or
five cuts of Alexander out their door
where our stone goes back I disagree
here's the thing I think when you watch
the movie especially confound sometime
actors they seem very theatric they're
almost over the top but I almost feel
like that says thing Oliver Stone was
going to you see interviews with him he
talks about the movies he grew up with
like Cleopatra had been her it was a
very theatrical kind of acting it was
very showmanship the emotions run
rampant throughout the whole movie they
just go for it and I feel like when I
watch this movie first of all on a
technical level
it's beautifully shot symmetry is
amazing some of the battle scenes this
movie opens up with a 20-minute battle
scene that I put up there with movies
from like gladiator Braveheart you name
it Dill's these bow scenes are right up
there with it the problem is I think at
the time it came out people were coming
off gladiator a very serious very
well-done film and they just weren't
quite ready for the kind of tone that
Oliver Stone was going for and I think
if you accept that going into the movie
you can actually have a really good time
of it all right fight it out y'all okay
all right know that okay first of all
yeah JT I mean Alexander which came out
in 2004 3 2004 1995 back to back to
Alexander I mean this is film but it's
been done it is one of Oliver Stone's
weakest movies I what's his name
cauliflower was was completely he was
overwhelmed by the scope of that movie
and it just it just was felt like a
cliched data that the battle scenes like
paled in comparison to like gladiator or
Braveheart
as far as showgirls showgirls you know I
been to a sold-out screening at the
scene espía and I was there when it was
at the birth we showed up but we have a
screening like that at a cemetery in
Hollywood you're preaching to the choir
so of course you're gonna get the fan
show I'm hang on showgirls showgirls is
a so bad it's good movie it is a bad
movie it's campy over-the-top it's
preposterous it's silly it's dumb it's
like a train wreck it is a train wreck
of a movie and you can't look away and
that is why people like to watch it but
greatest showman is actually a very good
film the production values the music
that designed they that wardrobe the
message of the film the performances it
is it is a some movie that really does
stay with you because it is a feel-good
crowd-pleaser and the fact that so many
moviegoers have defied critics the word
of mouth on that film was so strong and
that in say is a sort of slap in the
face to the critics who didn't get it
where
I point over to mr. dan Morello sitting
right there who was one of I'm assuming
the co-writers of the honest trailer of
the greatest showman which was [ __ ] well
there were so many songs in the greatest
showman that you guys were able to spoof
because you're talking about the message
of that movie PT Barnum was a ha okay so
you're saying 56 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes that's not that bad
bad and it did have huge box-office it
doesn't need a second chance because
it's already had a second chance
it had a successful first chance with
the writers of wala living Hugh Jackman
and Zac Efron give me a break dude it
doesn't talk it proposal Paul Verhoeven
the director of Total Recall and and
Robocop movie put him in movie Jail it
did not have a career because of this
film it also made because she's not the
best actress but what terribly reviewed
movie was actually a good movie we're
saying what deserves a second chance six
percent it's not a good it's not a good
rating at all it's a rotten music RM PT
Barnum was supposed to bad man
this is not a biopic this is a musical
fantasy it's the idea of what he started
it is not about the man himself movie
like greatest showman it's a ball he was
a bad man and the movie today in a
fictional New Guinea no it's not nobody
knows PT Barnum except for the circus
and that film so people having to grow
up and be like that's what that was
listen Alexander is garbage it is one of
those movies that I cannot even watch
what it's free on television like
Winstone watch it
you know I will tune in for Rosario
Dawson's but for like a second and a
half that's the only watchable part of
that movie if you turn up first of all
it's bad no ball just several cuts of
the film maybe you're talking about the
theatrical you probably haven't seen the
final cut or the ultimate cut you've
read many cuts it means that he didn't
know what he was not that different
though the cuts are not that different
oh they're very disturbed girl is what
you had there is something that is so
thoroughly enjoyable if it wasn't
enjoyable why did you go to a weird rug
because you went to a sold-out theater
ridiculous and crazy and over-the-top
and that is fun movies don't necessarily
have to be cinema sometimes they can
just be awesome entertainment and motion
to your final foster girls is awesome
entertainment there's also a reason that
this film was part of a tenth
retrospective because it deserves to be
memorialized it needs to be there are
people who can write papers on this
dissertations there is so much in this
in terms of sex politics gender politics
and the end when Nomi Malone becomes a
damn avenging angel and goes back to do
right for those who have been wronged
it is a morality tale it is about going
after your dreams
it has ridiculous high production values
it's so eminently quotable it is the
movie that what you you are never gonna
throw on Alexander when you're drunk
you're never gonna go to a cinema
screening when you're drunk you go for
enjoyment and you're never going to
enjoy any of these movies as much as you
will enjoy showgirls disagree completely
thank you okay yes I did go to that
screening at the senesce Piaf when I was
drunk and I sat there i sat there in the
audience and halfway through the film I
said out loud man this is a bad movie
everybody laughing cheering everybody
did it is they still enjoyed it and
whatever it is it's a bad movie I mean
just because it has a following doesn't
mean it's actually a good movie and it
didn't you know it has a cult following
it's a difference between having a cult
following and having a mass following of
Approval like the greatest showmen has
you can't get four hundred thirty five
million dollars worldwide for a movie
that's not even a frame
Chai's film that's extraordinary because
the word of mouth on this movie was so
strong because there was so much to it
it did it's not a biopic it is a musical
fantasy that had great musical numbers
it had a great message Hugh Jackman
Michelle Williams even Zac Efron and
zendaya they were all great in this film
this is a move that will stand the test
of time because it could prove that Hugh
Jackman is the greatest showman of all
thank you Scott
back around you Jake EE I'm gonna touch
you guys movies first for me
troll 2 room Birdemic you can find
sold-out theaters for this in Hollywood
because people like to go and enjoy how
bad they are so for you the fact that
you went to saw this was a bunch of
people don't joint for how bad it is
doesn't to me doesn't mean it needs to
be revaluated it's a bad good movie
that's basically what it is it's just a
fun time you like sit have some drinks
and just laugh at how bad it is your
film I think 50 56 % you said was our
experts not that bad a lot of people
loved the music
they went for the music they went for
the soundtrack the soundtrack probably
did just as good as the movie I don't
think you go to any four story
characters really anything else except
for the musical numbers now it is
musical I give it that but you have to
have more than that what takes away a
great musical for just a bad musical is
the story around the musical acts so for
me that movie is just it's a good music
movie that's it Alexander to me is the
movie that I think we really don't get
anymore was the last time we have like a
really big budget epic swords and sandal
movie I think Ben Hur was the last one
that was a remake which is a terrible by
the way not a good movie this movie is
one of the most historically accurate
films Oliver Stone did years and years
of research on this trust me and watch
the documentary that his son did on the
blu-ray and it's fascinating it makes me
very she ate the movie even more so I go
into the film I get to learn some things
I'm a history guy so I love learning
stuff especially when it comes to like I
could take it movie for him the best way
possible
Anthony Hopkins Val Kilmer Angelina
Jolie Jared Leto con Farrell rosario
Dawson they're all giving a hundred
percent to this movie they don't think
they're in a bad movie they think
they're making an epic in the form of
the olden days like Cleopatra and Ben
Hur
so for me this is Oliver Stone doing his
dream project is it gonna work for
everybody no it's not he's done a couple
different reef cuts that actually takes
scenes from the beginning movie
places him in the back like he does some
interesting things and I think you could
watch each one and honestly finally one
that kind of fits you best but for me
you might think that as a negative I
think that's good I think it's great
when the director could go back to his
work and rework it like that again Blade
Runner the tantric I never watch it
anywhere I'm not comparing the Blade
Runner and play funder I'm saying this
this is an interesting film that
director made and put his heart and soul
into and every performer is giving their
all and it is a beautifully shot film
you could turn this movie on mute what
you guys probably want to and it will
look freaking beautiful on whatever 8k
4k TV you have because it is really a
throwback to the old epics that I
absolutely loved and I was able to see
that in this movie and that's why I
think it needs a second chance because
nobody talks about it I get it you saw
the Attica version you're done the time
has passed
given our luck you might find something
we appreciate time all right how about
it dan Morelle yeah I want to see the
Snyder classic back so Dan will you
please give us the facts and then weigh
in with your opinions on this argument
showgirls the greatest showman and
Alexander got a 22% 56% in 16%
perspective right tomato rating on
Metacritic it was 16 for showgirls
generating what the site describes as
overwhelming dislike 48 on Metacritic
for the greatest showmen and 39 I met a
critic for Alexander then the statement
that Paul Verhoeven went to movie Jail
came up I be showgirls I know that's
entirely accurate he did make Starship
Troopers two years later he made
Holloman a few years after that so he
did generate a couple more movies in
pretty recent succession after showgirls
and JT asked about the certain samba
movies I think it can be argued that
Troy which came out the same year as
Alexander
later 300 were also in that genre so
similar big-budget
I said system but yeah we had Pompeii
here's a fact the greatest Roman also
has a remix album they haven't a went
platinum with their regular album and
then they also have a remix album that
like pink find it on iTunes
I
after the after the opening salvo I
really thought the Sasha had it by by
quite a large margin but first of all I
felt like Scott's pick was and and and
the other contestants brought it up but
it wasn't terribly reviewed and these
mixed reviews it made a lot of money it
was a very popular pick with audiences
so the idea that it needs a second
chance just really didn't land with me
because I agree with the the arguments
that it already it did well it did great
that its first chance so it was between
Sasha and jte for me and the more the
the more the fight went on actually it
became the more that Sasha and Scott and
the table we're talking about going to
these two these screenings of showgirls
that were sold out and everyone was
clapping and laughing and cheering that
in my mind I'm like that sounds to me
like a movie that's gotten a second
chance that people enjoy that they go
see the day that they like and then the
longer the JT talked about a director
Oliver Stone he put of this time into it
and it's a film that may have been
misunderstood and that has rediscovered
not so much that it's a great film his
that guru who takes he said it's not
what bad film is good it's what bad film
needs a second chance and throughout the
argument jte won me over just by arguing
that alexander take a second look give
it another chance i thought that was the
spirit of the argument and so I thought
that JT actually made the best argument
and my vote goes down all right that's
one for jte so for me I thought Scott
and Sasha knocked jte the f out with
were saying about Alexander and it came
down to Sasha and Scott for me but then
we came to the closing arguments where
JT II put on scrubs and gloves and
picked them apart like a GD surgeon your
closing arguments jte were fantastic and
you got up off the canvas like Rocky
himself and
yeah you just took this point jte hey I
gotta say though that not only if I was
judging not only what I've given Sasha
the point but I'd give her 10 bucks as
well because that was a hell of an
opening are my passion translates to
people watching it yeah where were the
polls and thoughts of the fans all right
so the fan say with 50% of the vote
Alexander % of the vote for the greatest
showman very glad that I didn't wind up
having to put my two cents in on
anything because the greatest Roman is
an awesome movie yeah for a lot of the
reasons Dan said the night love show
gross you would have made me bow to show
you the showgirls and it would have hurt
my heart were there any other fun
choices from everybody oh there were
tons of people talking about Man of
Steel we had some people bringing up
macGruber macGruber
someone said Fight Club which that's
another one where it's like no in my
college dorm room yeah any indication
plenty ha ha yeah a lot of someone said
Zoolander also mr. Benji builder men did
make us I don't know if we're gonna get
this because it's kind of dark Fozzie
bears the Empire
[Applause]
- you all right so the sports fan -
Scott - JT d1 Sasha looking to get on
the board question 3 the curse of ly
Llorona I hope I pronounced that right
yeah okay
liar ona opens this weekend part of the
conjuring family of films what's the
best horror movie specifically about
ghosts best horror movie specifically
about ghosts we were going to start with
player number three Scott mance okay the
best horror movie about ghosts is also
the best horror movie bar none of all
time and that is the shining because
what do you have going on at the
Overlook Hotel not only do you have the
downward spiral of Jack Torrance you
have a creepy hotel that is haunted by
ghosts and it's not just all in Jack's
buying because obviously we can see
right here that Danny Torrance sees the
ghost - and by the end of the film
so does Wendy what makes this movie
terrifying is the very intense
suspenseful pace established by the
master himself Stanley Kubrick you have
that ominous score this is a movie that
really gets under your skin and what
makes these ghosts dangerous are they
want this family dead they don't want to
just scare them away from the hotel they
want Jack Torrance to kill his family
and then they want Jack Torrance to kill
himself if that doesn't make these
ghosts dangerous more dangerous than any
other ghosts in any other film and hence
the scariest and best ghost horror movie
of all time then nothing does all right
Scott man's coming in with a classic The
Shining round the horn - gte so this is
a hard choice because I like all your
guys choices but I went with the film
called the orphanage it's a jo naam one
of his earlier films and for me the
ghost thing is really what I kind of
concentrated on this question Sandman
[Laughter]
about a woman who moves back into the
orphanage house that she actually grew
up with and was adopted from and flashes
back to a tragedy that happened when a
child went missing now I don't want I
might have to get to some Sparta - I'm
Terry towards the end here in order to
tie it to my fight huh all I'm gonna say
for now is that for me the way the
relationship to the ghost the relish of
the ghost have to the main character and
what she's dealing went throughout the
movie is so vital to the story it's not
just that ghost trying to scare people
they're not just being able to be able
it literally has a lot of layers to it
and as that movie peels away the layers
you become you go from terrified to
almost like sad and happy and to me I
just love how it runs the game of all
those emotions it's not just a ghosts
hiding in the painting or a scary ghost
walking down the hall there's so much
more to it and to me that's what makes
it the best ghost horror story all right
JT really connected with those ghosts so
I went with the sixth sense which I feel
like five four three two one
we all know the classic quote I see dead
people you have this beautiful little
boy played so brilliantly by Haley Joel
Osment who deals with seeing ghosts
being terrorized by that as a child like
trying to come to terms with that being
helped by dr. Malcolm crane played by
Bruce Willis so brilliantly and again
spoiler alert if you have not seen the
movie at the end of the film we come to
find out that Bruce Willis is one of the
ghosts that he sees oh this is sorry
sorry I know 26 years I apologize for
spoiling it it is so beautiful it's
heartbreaking it's terrifying Mischa
Barton doing her best acting work is the
little girl under the bed like there are
so many layers to this and I feel like
this is a brilliant horror movie because
it traumatizes us in the most small easy
familiar ways it gets under your skin
and makes you terrified - just like
trust the person you're speaking to toni
collette as Haley Joel Osment mother is
so beyond brilliant dan and I have
talked about this before hashtag justice
for Tony I mean unbelievable the child
performance this is M night Shyamalan at
his best I feel like this is Bruce
Willis when he was at the like the peak
of his powers it's so brilliant and it's
so heartbreaking and it makes you
actually really care about ghosts in a
different way like what are they going
through what's their plight to see the
story the Bruce Willis's character has
been dealing with Damn You Donnie
Wahlberg it is just brilliant it was a
shocking twist nobody could have
expected it is a fantastic film and a
great horror movie let's find it out
okay here we go
all right first of all the Sixth Sense
Sixth Sense which came out on August 6
1999 operating its 20th anniversary was
one of the best movies of 1999 and 1999
was a freaking operation area for fact
um but the Sixth Sense is a great film
but it's it's not a horror movie I
disagree it's a suspenseful movie yeah
but it is not a horror movie
it is it is not a scary film disagree
when I hang on I am making my camera
what I think of a horror movie I want to
be scared I want to be terrified The
Shining is a terrifying movie that movie
came out in 1980 it is almost 40 years
old I've seen a movie 40 times every
time I watch it I am still terrified by
that movie I cannot watch it in the dark
and I always sleep with the lights on
after the movie is over
Orphanage it's a very good film it's an
intimate film but I think of like a
horror movie a great ghost story a
horror movie ghost story the orphanage
isn't really in my top 10 I love the
film very much but it's not like when
you talk about the best horror movies
about a ghost that's not really there
and the sixth sense yeah it has a great
twist at the end but you know it so did
the shiny like you find out that Jack
Torrance was actually Dober Grady he was
actually he's all his destiny was always
to be at this hotel with that great last
shot of the New Year's Eve picture that
you see Orion on the internet film and
you're left to draw your own conclusions
and make up your own mind about what's
really going on
classic Stanley Kubrick that's why this
movie holds up so well and it
the greatest fur loss story hard movie
of all time just for the record for all
intents and purposes Sasha's choice six
cents is a horror movie it's in the
conversation so whether it is or isn't a
horror movie is not on the table let me
say I'm not gonna argue a lot about
Shining being a great movie that's one
of my favorite films of all time the
question is was best movie specifically
about ghosts the ghosts in shining
aren't just there to be scary and creepy
and there's like no motivation why do
they want people to die why do they want
Danny and his parents delight why do
they want Jack Nixon that kills family I
have no idea I could tell you why
because they're just ghosts they're not
what is it from the bucket from the moon
now it's from the movie on a burial
ground it was built on a burial place
they said and the Scatman Crothers
character said that a lot of bad things
happen at this hotel sure I don't know
when the battles where things are shiny
okay but to me again I love The Shining
but like the ghosts in that movie are
just there to be a haunted house movie
I'm there to show up at the end of two
girls just sitting there just blood
going down do these cool visions but the
ghosts aren't really like I said I like
a little bit more layers if I'm talking
about the best ghost horror movie of all
time the sixth sense is great I think
your your your mind kind of are very
similar because it's more about the
characters in a relationship to the
ghost and the scene with Hill josma and
Tony clay in the car fantastic but for
me the emphasis of the orphanage and as
the movie goes along her son goes
missing and she thinks you know she's
been kidnapped or something and it's
kind of starts off this mystery but then
that the usual haunted house elements
that you would see in the shining or
even The Sixth Sense start happening in
the movie and you're thinking myself
okay this is one horror horror movie 101
want to come to ghost but the end the
reveal of what actually happened her son
what happened to the kids in that
orphanage that are still there then it
out there just to be like scary we want
to kill you like something so bad
happened to them so so much injustice
happened to them that their souls are
stuck there and what happens the end of
this moon - I just spoil this movie yes
okay so bad scene it turns on to watch
it or don't three two one please so do
you want
the algorithm she finds out her son was
actually trapped in this secret room
underneath the house and the banging
that you would hear the scratch is that
you actually thought belonged to like a
ghost I was haunting them was her son
and she dies herself and becomes a ghost
and becomes like this surrogate mother
to all the children goes that were there
and it is so scary up into that moment
that when it happens you're like I went
from being like the most scared I've
been to in a ghost movie to like the
most like beautiful comforting scene of
a film that I've seen is similar to
again the sixth sense like I like how
that movie ends well the kind of like a
positive emotional note and I think my
movie does that but it also gives you
the scares i rewatch sixth sense last
year it's not very scary I mean I think
Shyamalan his style now is so familiar
to us that we watch one of his older
film do you just see every like little
trick of his coming like I'm just like
they have to Shyamalan yeah this is what
he does very little dialogue camera
sticks there doesn't show much and
what's a twist my twist is like
something that you get emotional
reaction from every time once you get
the sixth sense twist you just really
okay yeah I know what's gonna happen
it's not as emotional yeah he's dead I
know he's a ghost route the whole movie
to me it's a cool twist but the repeat
viewing while it might be fun to watch
to see the little Easter eggs the
emotional aspect for me to say isn't
really there let's move to final
thoughts
Scott okay first of all it's a call The
Shining just a haunted house movie no no
I'm talking he goes it's is it's like
calling Star Wars just another movie in
outer space
angry man you want to talk about layers
every freaking Stanley Kubrick movie has
lots of layers that's why they hold up
under repeated viewings and that's why
they they reveal new things the more
times you see it and that's definitely
the case with The Shining they made a
whole movie about sort of the
conspiracies of The Shining Cove room
and while The Sixth Sense okay for the
purposes of this argument yes it's a
horror movie but it's not scary if I
want to be I want to go to a to a heart
of ghosts movie a movie about ghosts a
horror movie about ghosts to be scared
shitless and the shiny scares me
shitless
it is widely hailed as the scariest
movie of all time at least in the top
three if not number one and is about
ghosts ghosts in a bath
tried to strangle Danny a ghost
it talked Jack Torrance into trying to
kill the rest of his family I mean these
ghosts mean business they want that
family not just out but dead that is
scary and it's disturbing on top of it
jte yeah are you shining fantastic
horror movie to me just for it to be
like a ghost story it just does it
really just kind of feels like all the
things you sustained the curry with the
layers that's in the filmmaking that's
stuff he does with the camera the set
design I love all that stuff but to me
that has nothing to do with the ghosts
the ghosts are just there to be scary
elements and to basically tell Jack
Nixon the kills family 6x8 is not that
scary to me
for me I think like it someone who kind
of knows tricks and he declined as a
filmmaker in my opinion after this after
his movie not breakable and going back
it kind of leaves a bad taste my mouth
when I go back and watch I'm like oh
yeah I'm on doing the shambhala I think
it just lost that excitement that when
it first came out that everybody was
talking about and again repeat viewing I
once you know that twist you know where
everything's going
someone just sticks on everything for so
long then you're just like alright let's
move we need to move a little bit
quicker because I know what's coming for
me the orphanage it has the best of both
worlds it is super scary kids dead cute
ghosts there's creepy man especially
they wear that mask that you see on
there like there's so many cool things
that Jay bond makes you think you're
watching a regular coast horror movie
and then he pivots and surprises you and
horrifies you at the same time and to me
that's just again more layers I think I
have the scares of the shining and the
heart in the emotion of 6 cents
both of my movie where I think you have
a little bit better with the horror you
have a little better with emotion but
mine has both and I think it makes your
most complete film SPR okay maybe I'm
just us I was scared shitless by the
sixth sense I don't think that this is
about what's the scariest movie it's
about what's the best about ghosts and
the thing is is what makes the shining
brilliant cuz this training is
unequivocably brilliant yes it is but
it's Jack Nicholson's portrayal it's
Jack Nicholson who you are truly afraid
of
it's the moment in the typewriter all
work and no play makes Jack a dull boy
which a human person wrote not a ghost
although
it's debatable like is the shining
really a ghost movie it's very very
debatable
it's a really great movie it's very very
scary I don't think that it holds up in
the same way like you're talking about
someone I'm like oh right that happened
The Sixth Sense is one of the best
movies of one of the best years of
cinema 1999 that we have had that's a
year where it was going up against Fight
Club abundance American Beauty there's
crazy things that you have to consider
and you're talking about M night
Shyamalan declining as a filmmaker I
think that we are having this
conversation with that bad taste in our
mouths because the truth is is the sixth
sense is a brilliant film that twist is
unbelievable and it showed you scary ass
children both alive and dead it gave you
great heart great emotion and at the end
of the day what you have is a film that
launched a filmmaker into another
stratosphere we're just pissed off at
him now because he disappointed us
because of the promise we saw with the
sixth sense that we didn't feel was
delivered upon that's why we're so angry
about it but it is unbelievable and
Haley Joel Osment is off the charts
brilliant in that film and Bruce Willis
breaks her heart and I think it is
everything that you want
it has scares it has a great redemption
it's the best one and it's very much
about ghosts time alright let's go to
the fact zone with mr. dan Murrow yes
okay Tony cloud received her first of
what should have been to success is best
supporting actress currently her only
Oscar nomination which again is a crime
against art cinema and humanity for the
people that are saying that six I must
be with Sasha assuming Sasha cos four
people saying that Sixth Sense is not a
horror movie the four means of vomiting
tent ghosts was different because I was
that kept me awake for like three nights
after I saw you it scared the bejesus
out of me yes and as far as the the the
Indian burial ground element of The
Shining if you know where to look JT
look at the Calumet baking powder in the
pantry man it's all
and if you haven't seen room 237 which
is a great documentary all about the
shining and it takes on like four
separate theories about what it was
really about watch it right now today's
exam one of them specifically references
the reading that the film is about the
treatment of American Indians Native
Americans by the Western colonizers it's
it's it's amazing people like zooming in
on cranes it's it's so fascinating so
check that if you have seen room 237
check better absolutely so yeah I
thought you know Scott definitely
launched into the lead with the shining
just end there's I mean how do you argue
against that movie Sasha had some really
great points about just the ghosts and
just the touching performance of Haley
Joel Osment but at the end of the day
just going to the the wording of the
question and the horror movie
specifically about ghosts when we were
able to click on the spoiler review and
but that's that's fine you really just
you like to touched my like heart and
soul with what I do win some justice
yeah with with the darkness that moved
into a whole other feeling in that movie
and someway somehow the orphanage beats
up a shining in sixth sense for me I'm
going with Dan for me the the argument
the whole round sort of ended up
settling out it was basically JT and
Sasha trying to convince me why their
movie was scary and and trying to
discount why Scott's a movie wasn't and
that's what it came down to for me and I
felt like ultimately Scott made a great
case for his film the orphanage sounds
great but it was more like GG was trying
to convince me to see a good movie that
I haven't seen I'm gonna say like why
this is the best and it might hurt that
he's up against two films that there's a
shorthand when you're talking about
sixes and and shining and then
I just think that that Scott was able to
knock away people he took the leader
going into the yeah it's the last leg of
the race and nothing I heard really
discounted that so I go with Skye okay
one for JT one for Scott Danielle could
you please settle Oh with 40% of the
votes the shining thirty two percent of
the vote the orphanage twenty six
percent of the vote is the sixth sense
other movies that were mentioned with
goosed
poltergeist which I think counts the
frighteners some people said the first
Ghostbuster is really scary if you were
a kid so I get that and then there were
some other ones that were mentioned
there was one called the others and one
horse Oh
all right Scott has three jts one Sasha
you were great and you're you're
rallying cry for showgirls is right up
there with John Belushi's rallying cry
from Animal House his powerful speech I
loved it all right but these gentlemen
are squaring off it's three four mance
one I don't think I have not had to
leave this law this big since I had two
kidneys hey now Scott a kidney donor
knew his brother my salute you sir all
right so it's game point going in moving
the speed round and it works the Slee
I'll ask the question shadow your answer
is the first one I hear then you will
get to elaborate first and we get 20
seconds 20 seconds and then ten seconds
ten seconds it's game point
first person to four wins Scott has a
3-1 game y'all ready for this it still
appears question one should rae end up
with kylo Ren at the end of episode 9
yes or no no oh I think I heard Scott
fer I heard Scott yeah a bit before yeah
a little bit a little bit before so no
JT you're gonna argue yes
Scott 20 seconds begin okay you know
what they've been sort of setting this
up that they were gonna be together ever
since the force awakens and definitely
into the last Jedi and I just thought
like the dialogue between the back and
forth of them it just it just they had
no chemistry even though they weren't
like in the same room at the same time
for a lot of that they just had no
chemistry it would be too easy to put
them together it would not be satisfying
a lot of people are kind of expecting
that to end up i totally disagree i
think they have a great chemistry do not
remember forced time AKA face time where
he's literally sitting without a shirt
and she's like sweating in the hut like
oh my god look all this man in front of
me
so for me you got to put these two
together it's called the rise of
skywalker
he's a skywalker he's gonna become good
they're gonna carry on a whole new Jedi
school together it just makes sense for
the story and honestly again I think the
chemistry is there okay that moment that
you're describing was silly people
laughed at the last Jedi during that
moment and that's another reason why
they should keep these two apart it
would be a disservice to the Star Wars
entire legacy to put these two together
I disagree I think they had great
chemistry and for you to say like they
shouldn't be together it makes the most
sense in this story Jay boyega is gonna
be with rose to me these two have the
story that in connected there's
something pulling them together whoa all
right first time face time let's go to
Danielle Radford um both of these
amazing arguments and I will say I did
write down for jte as a note sweating it
all that man unfortunately I'm going to
have to go with the other men's men's
okay that's one for manse Dan Morel mmm
this is very this is a closer than I
thought it would be I'm being honest
yeah I get the no chemistry but then JT
he sort of he parried the no chemistry
thing and then he had a bit of a pitch
of the new generation the rise of
Skywalker it was enough for me to kind
of go you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
lead towards JT on this one I agree I
got just enough from JT even though you
haven't mentioned how they worked in
unison in the throwing now in that
battle was how you like it was I was
pleasantly surprised by how powerful
your argument was I'm going JT it's
three - three - for the record I think
it would be a heinous mistake Yeah right
absolutely we're just going by what we
hear right here okay it's still game
point mr. mance
here you go dad thanks son in honor of
Hobbes and Shaw yep
what's the best movie with and in the
title so the title is like blank and
blank
state Maine State and Maine
Butch Cassidy the Sundance Kid oh okay
we got State and Maine and Butch Cassidy
and the Sundance Kid
Scott Matz i forfeit you David Mamet's
there's a flying blind here
conspiracy moment in sports mark hamill
provides the voice of Chucky in the new
child's play what actor would be the
worst choice to play Chucky TV Harmon
pee-wee Herman
[Music]
so Paul Rubens cuz pee-wee Herman is not
an actor that's a character so are you
saying Paul Reubens ain't pee-wee Herman
he was he was credited as pee-wee Herman
and pee-wee's big adventure in the
peewee films so and rural fact checks at
his fingertips we could count pee-wee
Herman as a separate actor from Paul
Reubens I believe so I don't know if
that you know what if I that makes sense
to me that makes sense to me okay
JT who would make their worst well
played Denver ah I'm gonna go with Seth
Rogen Seth Rogen okay we got pee-wee
Herman we got Seth Rogen we heard man's
first 20 seconds we can when you speak
okay it's Chucky it's all about the
voice because chalky doesn't look
menacing
he sounds menacing I'm what he does is
menacing but it's all down to the voice
nothing is anti menacing compared to
pee-wee Herman with his Emilio at the
little Mike get out there's no way
there's anything scary about pee-wee
Herman whether whether it's his book or
his voice I disagree pee-wee Herman was
a little off-putting to me as a kid my
mom won't let me watch this he saw son
was a little off that guy has a
be voice man that laugh alone if you
adult did that to me I would be scared
shitless Seth Rogen's laugh I would be
like oh come here buddy
you seem like a cool dude it's gonna
play like Ted three with Seth Rogen is
just gonna be comedic it's not gonna be
scary at all
pee-wee Herman can be scary okay you
want a Chucky movie to be scary
yeah and such broke and actually that
laugh that do that laugh could be scary
I want to go to a Chucky Buddha be
scared not to just be abused although I
want that too and with pee-wee Herman
I just screech Seth Rogen to me that
laugh is just comforting like it makes
me feel good pee-wee Herman's his voice
alone the man looks like a human doll
it's freaky
so he plays a little dog even more
freaked out at least Seth Rogen is just
gonna be popular whoa all right yeah I
thought Jane TV really parried in that
first round and cinched it in the second
I go jte Danielle I absolutely have to
agree these were both great arguments
but everything JT he was doing a really
good job of batting everything away
right work
JT you just won movie
[Applause]
jte well played my friend you have a
furious comeback I going in I was like
if I went out Xander and I won that one
not since the New England Patriots came
back against the Atlanta Falcons JT my
Patriot loving friend please go ahead
and yeah tell us where I can find you
give shout outs check me out on JT mu
things my YouTube movie review show
basically just movie reviews anything
outside come up with next week Avengers
and game review next Tuesday check it
out click I like it I like it
jte good stuff brother well fought Sasha
you are always the best thank you for
coming in here and shining your
ever-loving light on us my shining that
bet show girls light just like I need to
yes you guys can find me at saucer Pearl
River on Instagram and Twitter and
sitting there just counting the days
until that wild stallions 3 comes back
oh and my $10 at the club I'm just gonna
be sitting around waiting for John wick
3 Hobson JA oh my god Bill and Ted face
the music oh I can't wait man a lot of
good stuff on the horizon Thank You
Sasha dad so sorry my biological father
man well weed it's gotta be to this guy
yeah you're not gonna you're not gonna
take this loss out on me at dinner
tonight are you no you're not gonna go
to your room okay thank you it's on me
it's dad's fault I've seen Instagram and
Twitter at movie manse and check out my
everything I'm doing at movie manse calm
heck yes Scott thank you for bringing
the passion
cashy your fashion show girls now Dan
Murtagh thank you for bringing the facts
and I like to ask you this question
what's what's the box office look like
for the weekend well it's looking like
it could be a bit of a race Shazaam
probably not gonna be number one but
it'll be up there in the mix you have
the curse of La Jolla
I'm seeing it tonight I'm refusing
tomorrow I've seen it tonight I'll get
it right tomorrow right aroma is how
I've learned it in the in Spanish class
but I've heard a few different
pronunciations so I'm gonna take what
the movie says and that's what I mean to
go in but then also the brake
breakthrough breakthrough breakthrough
is also with the Easter crowd with the
the Christian throw um on Easter weekend
is a poised to potentially perform very
strongly so I think we could see a bit
of horse race for the number one box
office this weekend right on Danielle
how are you gonna be celebrating 420
this weekend same way I do every night
pinky I don't know I'm so boring I only
CBD just back pain like good it's Toder
yeah I've got things follow me on the
stuff follow me on twitter at daniel
Radford follow me on instagram at Daniel
- reffered okay bye right on please
follow Danielle Radford and follow me at
how I can die
yeah I mentioned 4:20 we are doing a big
4/20 show this weekend the tournament of
nerds is gonna be oh you're gonna be
like your Harold and Kumar is in there
and then we're gonna be talking about
like Oh what if Batman got high what do
we do stuff like that so if you are in
LA come to the tournament of nerds at
the UCB theater on Franklin Avenue
Saturday night at 11:59 p.m. and you'll
probably get a contact high from being
there it's a real 4/20 themed show I
want to thank everybody for watching jte
thank you for yeah just your furious
comeback thank you for being so
entertaining Billy Pitts thank you for
doing double-duty
and lighting the way and yeah we'll see
you next time whoo-hoo
[Music]
you